so we have here it says 2 times 4/3 is
equal to 8 times blank what I encourage
you to do is pause the video right now
and try to think about what should go in
this blank so I'm assuming you've given
your try now let's think through this
so 2 times 4/3 we can literally view
that as the same thing as if we rewrite
the 4/3 this is the same thing as 2
times instead of writing 4/3 like this
I'm literally going to write it as 4/3
and all I know it sounds like I just
said the same thing over again but I'm
going to write 1/3 for times 1/3 plus
1/3 plus 1/3 plus 1/3 this is literally
if you call each of these 1/3 there you
literally have 4 of them
this is 4/3 2 times 4/3 it's the same
thing as 2 times literally 4/3
now what would this be well this is
going to be equal to this is going to be
equal to let me just copy and paste this
it's going to be this 2 times so copy
and then let me paste it so that's one
group of those 1 thirds of those 4 one
thirds or one group of one of these 4/3
and then we'll have another one and
it'll have another one and we're going
to add them together
that's literally 2 times 4/3 so let's
add these together now what do we have
well we have a bunch of thirds and we
need to count them up we have 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 thirds this is literally equal to
and we could just to make it clear what
I've just done we could ignore the
parentheses and just add up all of these
things together so that might make it a
little bit clearer so let me do that
just to make it clear that I literally
take I've taken eight one thirds and I'm
adding them together which is the exact
same thing as eight thirds so let me
clear that and let me clear that clear
that and so this is literally or this is
clearly or hopefully clearly equal to
this is equal to
eight times 1/3 I have eight one thirds
there so going back to the original
question what is this equal to two times
4/3 is the same thing as 8 times 1/3 and
we've already seen that 8 times 1/3
well that's literally 8/3 so we could
also write it like this 8 over 3 let me
do that 3 in that other color 8 over 8
over 3